north korea has launched two ballistic
missiles according to
south korea and japan it's believed the
two short-range missiles flew 450
kilometers before landing in the sea
analysts say the country has a history
of testing
new u.s administrations with missile
launches
and other provocations to force the
americans back
to the negotiating table
well for more we're joined now by josh
smith a reuters correspondent based
in seoul good to see you josh tell us
what are we to make
of these missile launches are they
a message to the new u.s administration
or something else
well north korea conducts these kinds of
tests for multiple reasons not least
because it provides them
a good practical experience for
improving their weapons and also giving
training to their troops
but it's impossible not to see this in
context of the new administration and
the review the dividend administration
is conducting right now
it also comes as you mentioned after
north korea had rebuffed
biden's uh administration's attempts to
uh reach out to them
so in many ways this underscores what we
heard from north korea in a statement
last week which was
that it's not interested in speaking to
the united states but that
if it does come back to the negotiating
table it wants to do so on its own terms
well of course these missile launches
raise alarm bells
in the region what can you tell us about
how south koreans are responding to this
south korean officials here voiced deep
concern they
convened emergency meetings of national
security council
and said that they were working closely
with uh us intelligence
services and other allies um to address
this
at the same time the moon administration
here has been uh very eager to try to
restart engagement with
north korea um so while they're likely
to
continue to voice this concern they in
other ways may downplay this in an
effort to try to get those talks going
again
and what are the prospects for getting
those talks going again now that we have
a new administration in washington
uh well as we saw during the years under
the trump administration
north korea can turn on a dime going
from firing for fury then
to major summits with trump so it's
difficult to predict
but at the moment many analysts don't
expect north korea to return to talks
quickly
not least because they seem quite
focused on
issues at home including economic
problems and kind of fighting
the ongoing coronavirus problem josh
thank you so much for filling us in that
was correspondent josh
smith from the reuters news agency in
seoul
you